- [Female Voice] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(mellow music)
- Thank you very very much for asking me
to give a Howison lecture.
I'm humbled by the list of
nine years of predecessors
on this forum.
But I do have to begin
by explaining my title.
I'm talking about mathematics.
I have a very folksy eye
doctor who is a bit of a fan.
He said to me he had read a book of mine,
and he gave me a marvelous compliment.
He said, "You write just
like my third-grade teacher
"told me to write.
"Never use a 10-cent word when
a three cent word will do."
Well, of course, Proof,
Truth, Hands and Mind
are pretty expensive words,
but they're no more
than five letters long,
much better than 11-letter
words like mathematics.
But why my title?
First because proof has
been an essential part
of Western mathematics ever since Plato.
And Plato thought that mathematics
was the sure guide to truth.
I want also to think of
how we do mathematics
in a material way,
that Plato would hardly have acknowledged.
We think with our hands
and our whole bodies.
We communicate with each other.
Not only by talking and
writing but by gesticulating.
If I am thinking mathematically,
I may draw a diagram to take you through
a series of thoughts, and in this way,
I pass my thoughts to you.
I was astonished a short time ago
when an established
American poet, Kelly cherry,
wrote a poem, a sonnet about
me proving Godel's Theorem
in a logic class some 50 years ago
when I was a novice prof
and she was a grad student.
The poem describes me as
covering all four blackboards
in a room in Virginia with chalk,
gesticulating the while.
I still remember, she writes,
how you started on one
blackboard and worked your way
around the room, four walls whited out
in the blizzard of chalk.
The concluding couplet of the sonnet runs,
like gazing into someone's
mind and seeing his thoughts,
no two alike come into being.
Not a very good poem, the
book said out of the blue
but it surprised me by
expressing one of the connections
between mathematics and
the body that interests me.
And hence my mysterious title,
Proof, Truth, Hands and Mind.
But of course, there's
much more to the connection
between hands and mathematics
than gesticulating.
George Lakoff, here at
Berkeley has done much
to make us aware of how so
many mathematical concepts are
as he puts it embodied.
Mathematics is a specialist interest,
yet it's the only branch
of human knowledge
that has consistently obsessed
many of the dead great men
in Western philosophical canon.
Not all by any means, but
Plato, Descartes, Leibniz,
Kant, Husserl and Wittgenstein
form a daunting array.
And that omits the angry skeptics about
the significance of
mathematical knowledge,
such as Berkeley and Mill.
And the logicians such
as Aristotle and Russell.
If I cast my eye down this
list of Howison lectures,
I would add at least Michael
Dermott, Hilary Putnam,
Saul, Kripke and Quine to that list.
And in the opinion of some,
those are the most
important Howison lectures
that you read on that list.
Others would point to many
more distinguished speakers
who could care less about mathematics.
And yet a certain ideology of mathematics
has infected philosophy.
The terms of the bequest
of the Howison Lecture
which you can read here, penned in 1919,
use an idiom that few of us or none of us
would use today.
It tells us that Prof.
Howison thought of the world
as a community of free
persons, finite and infinite
sustained by a vision of the perfect,
perfect with a capital P.
And where did this vision originate?
In Plato's conception of mathematics.
Why has mathematics mattered so much
to so many famous philosophers?
Aside from the naysayers such as Mill,
it's first of all because they
have experienced mathematics
and found it passing strange.
The mathematics they have encountered
has felt different from other experiences
of learning discovery
or simply finding out.
Now, many people do not
respond to mathematics
with such experience or feelings.
They really have no idea what
is moving those philosophers
and they're in good company.
Take David Hume, one of my
heroes who can do no wrong.
I doubt that he had a mathematical moment
in his entire life.
Experience in mathematics
in no way implies
the possession of philosophical
gifts or vice-versa.
But those philosophers who
have experienced mathematics
have built it into their conceptions
of pretty well everything.
So what is philosophy of mathematics?
There are three types
of philosophical issues
about mathematics, I call them ephemeral,
scholastic and perennial.
The ephemeral ones are the pressing ones
arising out of recently discovered
but disquieting mathematical facts
we have not yet figured
out how to live with.
Ephemeral doesn't mean unimportant,
it means present but
perhaps not long-lasting.
Most generations during
which mathematical research
has been intense produce
their own ephemeral
philosophical difficulties.
Mathematicians worry
about them just as much
or more than philosophers do.
What I call the scholastic issues,
again not with a negative
sense, no more than ephemeral
are usually generated
within philosophy itself
and are almost unknown outside it.
The perennial questions
are for everyone including
and maybe especially including beginners.
There are a few topics
that are easily grasped
if you have any live experience
of mathematics at all.
They've always been there and
they're not going to go away.
I have no intention of
making them go away.
I shall touch on the
ephemeral but more briefly
than I would like.
The issues really matter
to how we should think
about mathematics now in 2010.
But they're not my primary topic,
I shall sketch a few,
'cause it seems to me
that far too many
philosophers of mathematics
intent on scholastic issues tend
to ignore pressing matters
arising from current math.
In contrast, I shall bypass
what I call scholastic matters,
and so this talk will not much resemble
most current literature in the
field of academic philosophy.
Instead, I shall strive
for a second adolescence
and address perennial
questions which in my opinion,
are the reason why there is
philosophy of mathematics at all.
Second adolescence, I've
written far too many books
but not published almost
nothing about mathematics.
Yet it was my first love.
My PhD thesis came in two parts.
One was called Proof,
first word of this lecture.
The other, of 30-odd pages
had nothing to do with it
but proved some results in logic.
Happily, the examiners liked
the latter and they passed me.
But I had been gnawing at the topics
of the other thesis, Proof, all my life.
And I finally venture 50 years later
to continue writing that thesis.
And the talks I am giving
this week including this one
are different aspects of that project.
I have been quietly obsessed
by Wittgenstein's remarks
on the foundations of mathematics,
ever since I bought the book
on the 6th of April 1959.
And my dissertation was a
first passionate confused
expression of the effect
of that book on an
as yet unformed mind.
If Professor Tahara is present tonight,
he can witness that I was
impassioned with the remarks
when we were both very young
and knew each other very briefly.
I do however, take up new topics
which it would have been hard
to think about 50 years ago.
Proof, I want to say
something about the first word
in my title.
Proof has been a hallmark
of Western mathematics
descended from Greece.
There was plenty of what we can recognize
as mathematical thought in ancient China,
Egypt, Babylonia, possibly in Mesoamerica.
We might venture this.
As soon as the people
had invented writing,
they were ready to invent mathematics
and maybe the Inca did it
without inventing writing.
But writing enabled us to
tap cognitive skills in ways
very difficult without it.
But the existence of proofs
is due to a curious historical accident.
A handful of people in
the eastern Mediterranean,
Greeks as we call them,
discovered the very possibility
of deductive proof.
They happened to live in
an argumentative society,
a few of whose members
wanted a better tool
for settling arguments than rhetoric.
I want to remind you of
Kant's story of this,
were heirs to this critical
anomaly in human thought.
In the traditional story,
relayed by Aristotle,
a legendary (mumbles) discovered proof,
and all the greats repeat
what Aristotle passed on.
It's not terribly good
history in our present opinion
but it's an important parable.
A short time, Kant, a
short time after publishing
the first edition of The
Critique of Pure Reason in 1781,
Kant caught the wave of the future,
something not often noticed
and became something
of a historicist about human reason.
The new introduction to the second edition
of the first critique, 1787,
Pure Reason Has a History.
I love his rendering of the
story of the light bulb going on
over the head of Thalys or some other.
He writes, in the earliest
times to which the history
of human reason extends,
mathematics among that wonderful people,
the Greeks had already entered upon
the sure paths of science.
The transformations must
have been due to a revolution
brought about by the happy
thought of a single man.
The experiment which
he devised marking out
the path upon which the science must enter
and by following which secure
progress throughout all time
and in endless expansion
is infallibly secured.
You didn't know Kant went
in for purple prose perhaps.
And he speaks about how the history
of this intellectual
revolution has been preserved
in a way which at least
shows that the memory
of the revolution brought
about by the first glimpse
of this new path must have
seemed to mathematicians
of such outstanding
importance as to cause it
to survive the tide of oblivion.
A new light flashed upon
the mind of the first man,
be he Thalys or some
other who demonstrated
the properties of the isosceles triangle.
Now of course, we would not do all this,
it requires a community,
we would not do it, a
single man and all that
but there's a remarkable
parable here being told by Kant.
In the opinion of one of the
most interesting historians
of mathematics revealed, Greek
mathematics revealed, Netz
something tumultuous took place
involving a small number of individuals
who corresponded and traveled
in the eastern Mediterranean.
Using the metaphor recently
favored in paleontology,
Netz suggests to quote,
the early history of Greek
mathematics was catastrophic.
Fantastic changes.
A relatively large number
of interesting results
would have been discovered
practically simultaneously.
Now, maybe this is no
more than a just so story,
but it is a great parable .
Like so many parables, it cuts two ways.
In a brilliant critical
notice of Netz's book,
Bruno Latour has recently written,
Bruno Latour is a
sociologist of knowledge,
the one who has most
influenced my own thought
who says that Plato
kidnapped mathematical proof.
Kidnapped, making it a cornerstone
of his epistemology and metaphysics
and he's quite rude about Plato.
To the great surprise of those who believe
in the Greek miracle, the striking feature
of Greek mathematics according
to Netz, writes Latour
is that it is completely
peripheral to the culture,
even to the highly literate one.
Medicine, law, rhetoric,
political sciences,
ethics, history, mathematics no
with one exception, the
Plato Aristotelian tradition.
But what did this tradition,
itself very small at the time
take from mathematics?
Only one crucial feature,
that there might exist one way to convince
which is apodictic and
not rhetoric or sophistic.
Philosophy extracted from mathematicians,
not a full-fledged practice but only a way
to radically differentiate itself through
the right manner of achieving persuasion,
which he thinks, which
of course Latour thinks
is all a con trick.
And Latour speaks for myriads who say
that they hate or fear mathematics.
If you had to suffer through
geometrical demonstrations
at school which is
certainly the case for me,
he writes and so on.
Now, I'm in the minority.
In fact, I am lucky enough to have gone
to a mediocre high school long ago,
a rather unreformed
place where I had to do
slightly watered-down Euclid,
and in my case it was
at the age of 13 or 14.
Nerd I was, so I loved Euclid.
It was my escape from a
harsher world around me.
I learned about proofs and I loved them.
So I am a gullible victim
of Plato's abduction
of mathematics and the victim Kant.
But do we need proofs?
Little sketch I've given is
highly contingent events,
flukes of happenstance.
We have by good fortune
an experimental illustration of that.
China in ancient times,
developed brilliant mathematical ideas.
But it chiefly worked on
a system not of proofs
but of approximations.
Proof seldom reared its
head and was seldom esteemed
in its own right.
Geoffrey Lloyd, comparative
historian of Chinese
and European intellectual history suggests
the hierarchical structure of
a powerful education system
with the emperor civil service
as the ultimate Court of
Appeal had no need of proofs
to settle anything, whereas a democratic,
very oligarchic, but I
mean limited in democracy,
democratic society like Athens
where you had to argue things out,
at least to an anti-Democrat like Plato,
proof was a wonderful
replacement for rhetoric.
We could have gone on
just fine without proof.
We could have been Chinese
using a sophisticated
method of approximate
solutions and got ourselves
to the differential
calculus that way, directly
if we had fast computers long ago
who would have needed proof.
I don't support that line of thought
about what we could have
done, because I think proof
is so intimately embedded in the history
of the Western sciences as a model,
often for the worse rather
than for the better.
But we just could have
done without the concept
in practice of deductive
proofs, but that's where we are,
that's what we have and we still have it.
Now, I was once keen on
proofs but then let them rest.
But there are advantages
to being Rip Van Winkle.
Rip slept for only 20 years which happened
to span the American Revolution.
I'm a Rip who has stayed
away from mathematics
and its philosophizing for
no fewer than 50 years.
Hence I am struck by some
radical changes that may escape
the notice of those who
have come upon the scene
more recently or have been able to watch
it evolve continuously.
There's of course a lot more mathematics.
There are not just new questions
but new classes of problems
and new methodologies,
new techniques pretty much unthinkable
until quite recently.
I think it's not just a matter of degree,
but doesn't matter.
Rip Van Winkle has difficulty
catching up on the new math.
But he easily notices changes in the way
in which mathematicians of various sorts
talk about their field.
He attends to the new gossip.
I shall single out four
changes as done deeds.
Certainty, kinds of evidence,
experimental mathematics and application.
These lead on to what I have
called ephemeral issues,
important topics that
arise from mathematics
as she is practiced right now.
Certainty, mathematics used to be admired
as the only certainty.
Any of you who have read
Bertrand Russell's biographies
or autobiographies will know
what he vowed as a young man
to make mathematics completely certain.
Mathematicians have finally
allowed themselves to be relaxed
about what would once have been scandal.
Published proofs are full of gaps,
even though the result proved
is usually more or less right.
One mathematician, Richard Borcherds
of the math department here,
he won a Fields Medal in 1998,
casually asked me at our first meeting
after we had discussed his own work,
if anyone had looked at the
error rate of the proofs
in Principia Mathematica,
especially volume three.
The very concept of an error
rate in published proofs
was to my knowledge non-existent
or unmentionable 50 years ago.
Now it's a common place anywhere.
Once it seemed a terrible
insult to the queen of sciences
that proofs are full of holes.
Experts now expect that and
accept it, so long as one sees
pretty clearly how to
clean up the odds and ends.
Sometimes it matters, and the
proofs are deeply fallacious.
In important cases, one worries.
But in general certainty has
become a matter of degree.
These thoughts have
become common parlance.
During the last 50 years, the old vision
of absolute mathematical
certainty which Kant
took for granted and which drove Russell
to spend the best years of his
life toiling with Whitehead
on Principia, they're all history.
Second, kinds of evidence.
It's now publicly acknowledged
that all sorts of evidence
may be used in support of
mathematical propositions.
Proofs are important,
perhaps they still define
the discipline but the
working mathematician
uses all sorts of
non-demonstrative reasoning.
A nice example of sheer
hands-on experimentation
is in packing problems.
What's the best way to
fit a bunch of tetrahedra
into a container, which actually has a lot
of important applications.
People do that with real
little plastic objects.
Pieces from Dungeons and Dragons
are the cheapest tetrahedra in town,
and they also do it by
computer simulations.
More generally, there is
a widespread awareness
that demonstrative proof
is not as important
as it seemed to be.
George Pólya in 1945 had already shown
that all sorts of
non-deductive good reasons
arise in mathematical thought.
Polya's one-time student, Imre Lakatos
wrote his brilliant proofs and refutations
to show that all mathematical
proofs are fallible.
The Procedure of Proof is what
he called quasi empirical.
Only at the end of a
Hungarian synthesis of proof
and refutation might one produce something
that amounted to analyticity.
But it's not Lakatos that made or Polya
that made mathematicians come out
of the closet about fallibility.
There's a much richer internal story
that demands serious sociological study.
One thing with which it's connected
is the most radical single
change to have a chord
in mathematics these 50 years,
namely fast computation.
This has become an almost invaluable tool
for mathematical exploration.
In the early days, computers
were merely prosthetics,
sort of a better pencil.
What matters today are how
computers help us to explore.
So experimental mathematics.
There's been a lot of discussion
by both mathematicians
and philosophers about proofs,
checkable only by computer
and about computer generated proofs.
The prime example to which
philosophers usually turn
is the four-color theorem proved in 1977.
Far more important in
my opinion is the advent
of large-scale experimental
mathematics with its own journal
Experimental Mathematics,
founded by David Epstein in 1992.
David just happens to have been one
of my undergraduate chums.
To avoid misunderstanding, it
was emphasized from the start
that this was a journal
of pure mathematics.
The point was not to deny
the claim that I shall make
about pure and applied
mathematics in a few moments,
but to make plain that the
journal was not interested
for example in the booming industry
of simulating experiments
in the material world,
an activity that depends
of course on the constant
use of mathematics both in modeling
the micro and macro universes around us.
But also in designing programs
in which the models are embedded.
Thus far, most philosophers
seem to have discounted
experimental mathematics as nothing new.
I think not enough attend
to the way in which
it is such an extraordinary tool
for mathematical exploration.
Perhaps an awoken Rip Van
Winkle can arouse his colleagues
from dogmatic dozing.
How about this for a sentence
destined to rouse hackles?
Experimental mathematics
provides the best argument
for Platonism in mathematics.
At any rate, as David
Epstein wrote me recently,
these are things that no one dreamt of
when we were students.
Sometimes what is found
out is quickly replaced
by a deductive proof.
Some of those deductive proofs
are old-fashioned proofs
that make sense.
Others are themselves
only machine checkable.
Here there is a real division of attitude.
Some mathematicians regard
computers merely as tools
of discovery or as search
machines for counter examples,
after discovery comes justification.
Others think this attitude is obsolete.
I don't take sides.
Mathematicians differ.
Timothy Gowers, a Cambridge mathematician
who won a Fields Medal in 1998,
same year as Richard Borcherds,
is the author of a wonderful book,
Mathematics: A Very short
Introduction, in which he writes,
my own view which is a minority one
is that over the next 100 years or so,
computers will be eventually
supplanting us entirely.
But he continues, most
mathematicians are far
more pessimistic or
should that be optimistic
about how good computers
will ever be at mathematics.
Incidentally, and perhaps it is relevant,
I have encountered very
few working mathematicians
who take Wittgenstein seriously.
Gowers writes at the
end of his little book,
anybody who has read both this book
and the philosophical
investigations will see
how much the later
Wittgenstein has influenced
my philosophical outlook
and in particular,
my view on the abstract method.
But now with computers,
we enter a strange region.
We tend to think of computers
as never making mistakes
but computers are imperfect,
and their error rate is far greater
than their manufacturers acknowledge.
This has become a little
branch of mathematics
in its own right.
For a exaggeration, Roger Penrose argues
that all computation is a
quantum sensitive operation
that is, its probabilistic only.
It only takes one cosmic
ray to turn a zero into one
and make a different computation.
So here is one more ephemeral
problem which of course
might go on troubling
us for a very long time.
Applications, another change.
There was in 1960, something of a Cold War
division of opinion.
Soviet Dogma held that pure mathematics
was bourgeois idealism,
and that only applied
mathematics was substantial.
But in the West, where what we call
the philosophy of
mathematics was practiced,
the concept of pure
mathematics was dominant
not only among philosophers but among
many schools of mathematics.
It was a curious situation, for
never before had mathematics
such an effect on the world.
In 1960, everyone was
aware of the possibility
of blowing everything
up and was busy digging
futile bomb shelters or
walking from Aldermaston
with the campaign for nuclear disarmament.
Perhaps that was the very
reason that mathematicians,
ostrich-like wanted to
maintain their purity.
I believe that the sharp
distinction between pure
and applied mathematics was
an aberration that is past.
A lovely end of career
account of the reunion
of pure and applied is to be found
in a recent survey article
called Geometry and Physics
by Michel Atiyah who won
his Fields Medal long ago
and an Abel prize recently.
The doors between pure and
applied have been unlocked.
Mathematicians have had to learn
how to think like physicists.
Not only metaphorically
unlocked but literally,
in Atiyah's case.
It seems that when he was at
MIT, he discovered that a door
separating mathematics and
physics was permanently locked
in the building or the extended
building in which he worked.
Why?
Well, the physicists had
just installed new carpeting
and didn't want the grubby
mathematicians messing it up
with muddy snow on their boots.
Peter Galison tells of a
countertop that can ensue
when the mathematicians and the physicists
get different answers.
In his example, the physicists were right,
their sense of how the
physical world works
trumped the mathematicians'
conception of space.
In retrospect, one just says that somebody
made a programming
error but that is really
not to get at the heart of it.
I'll give just one example
of how the boundaries
between pure and applied sort of collapse.
It's a real-life example
quite easy to understand.
It's rigidity.
Nothing it seems could be
more practical than rigidity.
As soon as human beings
began to build shelters,
moved out of caves, they wanted structures
that would not fall down.
Some predecessor concept of
rigidity must have emerged
very early in human consciousness.
Not as a cognitive universal
but as an ecological one.
Take only a very late civilization
about which we actually know something.
The two classic structures
of the North American prairie
where building materials are scarce
are the wigwam and the teepee.
The former, the wigwam, is
a fairly permanent structure
in which height is fixed
around a domed frame
made of branches and
the latter as you know
is built around a movable frame of poles
that becomes rigid when erected.
Now, there's a wonderful
mathematics of rigidity.
Some say it goes back
to Euclid but in 1814,
Cauchy, the French mathematician proved
the foundational theorem
that any convex polyhedron
with rigid plates but
with hinges at its edges
is despite the hinged edges rigid.
Here we move from a serious
practical problem, what stays up
to pure mathematics, an entire discipline
which becomes an aspect
of topology develops.
But then real life strikes back,
and the mathematicians
learn from the engineers.
One of the loveliest rigid
structures is the geodesic dome,
often called the Bucky dome
after Buckminster Fuller,
who worked out some of its a principles
and patented it in 1954.
It's a network of great circles
that interform to triangles.
Much the same effect by the
way seems to have been achieved
by wigwams built by Apache Indians.
Fuller generalized the concept of rigidity
to what he called tensegrity,
tensional integrity,
based on a balance between
tension and compression
which has a lot of
engineering consequences
both in the large and the small.
That is totally applied
science but tensegrity
has generated its own rich
and aesthetically pleasing
field of mathematics.
Late in the 19th century,
a french engineer,
precise engineer, discovered
flexible non-complex polyhedron.
But it was long thought that
any polyhedron homeomorphic
to a sphere has to be rigid.
In 1978, Robert Connelly at
Cornell found a flexible,
(mumbles) vertex counting (mumbles),
does this research have
practical consequences?
Not obviously.
One application of
Connelly's discovery is one
can make a flexible
polyhedron for exhibition.
According to Wikipedia,
there's one in Washington
at the National Museum
of American history.
I don't know why it's not
the Smithsonian but there.
Well, that's an application
which we should not forget
in thinking about applications,
what I call a secondary application namely
to enchant schoolchildren with
the wonders of mathematics.
Connelly's polyhedra are
in familiar three-dimensional space.
Flexible polyhedra are
known and for space.
Are there any flexible polyhedra in more
than four dimensions?
A question investigated at present
for purely aesthetic reasons,
the answers are not known.
So it's pure for the nonce.
I want also to say a word
about the application
of mathematics to mathematics.
Descartes wrote the
first canonical textbook
of analytic geometry, The Geometrie.
We often forget it was
published as an appendix
to the discourse, that is the discourse
of properly conducting one's reason
and seeking the truth in the sciences.
I like to think of his geometry as a model
of how to conduct one's
reason and seek truth.
The geometry made plain, what
I mean glimpsed at before
for all the world to see that
algebra born of arithmetic
could be applied to geometry.
It's the first indubitable example
of the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics
developed for one purpose
applied to mathematics
developed for another purpose.
And I'm dead serious in making a statement
parallel to the physicist
Eugene Wigner' statement
1960 article, Unreasonable
Effectiveness of Mathematics
in the Natural Sciences.
Wigner's title is often read
as the unreasonable applicability
of mathematics to physics.
Descartes gave a stunning example
of the unreasonable applicability
of mathematics to mathematics,
now why is it unreasonable?
Because it's almost too good to be true.
Geometry is spatial, algebra
is a child of arithmetic.
Arithmetic is for counting,
a process that as Kant
emphasized takes place in time
once you get past the point
of just seeing how many
that is past six or so.
Kant used his thought of the
distinctness of space and time
manifested by the difference
between geometry and arithmetic
as the road to an entire
critical philosophy
that has haunted us ever since.
It would be a plausible
conjecture for those
who take a modular view of the brain,
that the modules that
enable us to navigate
our spatial environment and
invite geometry are distinct
from those that gave us the number sense
to use the title of a
book by Stanislas Dehaene.
Somehow the two coalesce, how come?
Well, that's not an ephemeral question
but as a matter of fact, it's not one
which philosophers have addressed.
The history of mathematics is one
of diversification and unification.
We start with diversity.
Some peoples, the ancient
Greeks fixed on geometry
as primary while others in
India and working in Sanskrit
fixed on numbers as primarily
and bequeath that obsession
to Islam and Arabic,
but it all keeps turning
out to be the same stuff.
And if you read science journalism,
you'll know for instance
that one of the reasons
that Andrew Wiles's
result on Fermat's Last Theorem is deemed
to be so exceptional and
create new proof ideas
was that it brought together
branches of mathematics
which seemed to have nothing whatsoever
to do with each other.
But there's something special
about arithmetic and algebra
on the one hand and geometry in the other.
Perhaps it's only a contingent fact
about the historical
development of mathematics
as we know it, but there's a strange play
of arithmetic and geometry
throughout our experience.
Descartes is a focal point in that dance.
Category theory can be seen
as starting from the premise
that the two are the same,
and seeing what happens.
So understood it would be a fulfillment
of a Cartesian insight that
geometry and algebra are one.
I think that the question
about algebra and geometry
is one that deserves much thought
and which is not ephemeral
but it does not bear on my lead question,
why is there philosophy
of mathematics at all?
First Russell's answer,
why is mathematics exercise
such a powerful effect?
When he had finished
and done with Principia,
Bertrand Russell sat
down to write a potboiler
that has charmed young people ever since,
The Problems of Philosophy
in 1912, it charms me still.
In the course of covering
the waterfront, he wrote,
every philosophy which
is not purely skeptical
must find an answer to Kant's question,
how is mathematics possible?
Of course, Russell exaggerated.
Some great philosophies that
are not purely skeptical
have had no interest in
mathematics whatsoever.
What's so strange about
mathematics that it should
however attract so many philosophers?
Russell mentioned one source of wonder.
The apparent power of
anticipating facts about things
in which we have no
experience is very surprising.
That's a much better way of putting things
than Kant's glorious exclamation of awe,
the one that put together
our philosophical argo.
In the (mumbles) any future
metaphysics that will be able
to present itself as
a science, that's 1783
between the first edition of the critique
and what I call the historicist
edition of the critique,
we get the question for
the first time in Kant,
how is pure mathematics possible?
And it's a sort of shout.
Here is a great improved
field of knowledge
which is already of admirable compass
and for the future promises
unbounded extension
which carries with it
thoroughly apodictic certainty
that is absolute necessity,
hence rests on no grounds of experience
and is a pure product of reason.
And moreover is thoroughly synthetic.
How is it possible for
human reason to bring
into being such knowledge wholly a priori?
There we have the
philosopher's words, a priori.
Synthetic and qualified by
adjectives that turn a noun
into a sort of shout.
Apodictic certainty, absolute necessity.
Yet that doesn't explain
why so many philosophers
should be obsessed by mathematics.
The words are more names
for aspects of an obsession
than explanations of that obsession.
Proof and application when combined point
to a reason why there has been
a philosophy of mathematics
ever since Plato.
In fact, Plato is I
think the first example
of genuinely unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics.
In the 13th and last book of the elements,
Euclid constructed a
regular convex polyhedron
and proved there are only five of them.
Some scholars have argued
this is the conclusion
which was the whole point of the elements.
We call these five polyhedra
the Platonic solids.
In the time is, Plato
proposed that the elements
of which the universe are built
are shaped as regular solids.
There was plenty of
pre-Socratic speculative physics
but Plato took mathematics
devised for supposedly
aesthetic reasons and applied
it to speculative physics.
It may be the first
known case of a primary
and theoretical
application of mathematics.
At any rate, neither proof
nor application suffices
on its own to keep the ball rolling,
but together they are a force
which must be reckoned with.
Yet something else is even
closer to the experience
of mathematical proof.
It's the sensation that
mathematics is just out there.
And where is there?
Now that's a problem
but I take the sensation
very seriously indeed.
It's why I talk about the experience
of mathematical discovery.
It seems no more than a vulgar
way of describing Platonism.
Indeed, it may appear to
be the most crass form
of Platonism imaginable.
It's the very crassness
that brings it close
to the roots of the
philosophy of mathematics.
Philosophizing about mathematics
is haunted by Platonism,
both naive forms and sophisticated forms.
It's supposed to be a kind of ontology,
but one is tempted to
recycle Jacques Derrida's
brilliant pun and call it hauntology.
Until December 5th, you can
see the hauntology exhibit
at the Berkeley Art
Gallery just up the street
and you can read phrases like,
such an uneasy mixture of
the ancient and the modern
which are applied to a
particular form of British jazz
or British music making, sorry.
But one could apply the same
thing to Platonism itself,
an uneasy mixture of the
ancient and the modern.
I'm afraid to say the art gallery
is cashing in on Halloween
and on this coming Friday, the 29th,
they are having a sort
of hauntology party.
But I think hauntology is
really a very serious idea.
I'm not a Derrida admirer
but I think that pun
is really enormously thoughtful.
No ghost more effectively
haunts all Western philosophy
than Plato's, and sometimes
I wish for an exorcist.
Platonism in its various
guises and disguises
will never be exorcized.
I find it best to say that
in its strongest forms,
it is a pleasant fable,
while in its more modest forms as banal.
One logician, Bill Tate,
exemplifies the view
that when properly stated, it is trivial.
I do tend to agree with an
idea I attribute to Nietzsche
that European languages demand
an existential presupposition
for the terms in the subject position.
European grammars generate
the feeling that if there
are truths about numbers,
then numbers exist.
This Nietzschean idea is
intended to undermined interest
in the existence of numbers.
Their existence is a trifling
byproduct of our grammar.
One can also say what the
mathematician, Timothy Glowers
whom I referred to before
got from Wittgenstein,
that it's what we do that
matters, and in the way in which,
well it's the same way in
which the piece in chess,
the King's rook, it's
not an abstract object.
It is rather what it can do
which constitutes its reality.
There are many scholastic physicians here.
Quine had what called the
indispensability argument
which is supposed to settle the question,
numbers and functions do exist
because we quantify over them
in the Natural Sciences.
Quine's maxim, to be is to
be the value of a variable.
Numbers are values of variables
in contemporary physics,
that's our best available
theory of how things are
hence numbers exist which
means that in some sense,
Platonism is true, QED.
And there are widespread
opposition to this.
Perhaps some of you
will know Hartree field
or doctrines of fictionalism,
structuralism advocated
by Charles Sahera among others
holds that what exists are
not mathematical objects
but mathematical
structures and they exist.
Normalists think that's
pretty cold comfort
and there's some truth in their reaction.
There really is nothing more
to numbers than their relations
so numbers, anything you say about numbers
are about structures and Plato
need not have been very
perturbed by structuralism.
The numbers are characterized
by certain structures
and there are structures
instantiated by numbers.
it's still kind of Platonism.
Now, I apologize for this gross
superficiality, you experts.
I want only to emphasize that
these skirmishes and alarms
are generated within philosophy itself.
They're scholastic, not
in any pejorative sense
but only in the sense
that they are of interest
to those who participate in the activity
of academic analytic philosophy.
Many mathematicians are content
to call themselves Platonists.
Is a single one of them moved by the fact
that all the sciences quantify
over numbers, I doubt it.
They're moved by the fact that
they discover amazing facts
about numbers by means of
proof or rumors of proof.
At least some mathematical
objects are experienced
as out there or structural
relations between them
are experienced as out there.
What's this out there?
It's convenient to use a debate in which
a self-declared Platonist
mathematician faced off
against a nominalist neurobiologist.
The protagonists were two
French colleagues of mine,
Alain Connes and Jean-Pierre Changeux,
published a book in French in 1989
and slightly expanded in English in 1995.
Alain Connes who received
the Fields Medal in 1982
cannot doubt there is a
mathematical reality out there
independent of human thought.
Changeux is convinced that
mathematical structures
are byproducts of the innate
endowments of the human brain.
I suspect that these two
attitudes are compatible
but fortunately Conne and
Changeux do not think so.
Fortunate because some lines are drawn.
I don't say they're drawn
clearly, but clear enough
that we can look at them.
Connes was enormously
impressed with the fact
about mathematical research.
Here we come, he writes, upon
a characteristic peculiar
to mathematics that is
very difficult to explain.
Often it is possible although
only after considerable effort
to compile a list of mathematical objects
defined by very simple conditions.
Intuitively, one believes
that the list is complete
and searches for a general
proof of its exhaustiveness.
New objects are frequently
discovered in just this way
as a result of trying to
show the list was exhaustive.
Take the example of finite groups.
The notion of a finite
group is elementary,
almost on the same level
as that of an integer.
A finite group is the group of symmetries
of a finite object.
Mathematicians have struggled to classify
the finite simple groups, that is to say,
the finite groups that like the
prime numbers to some extent
can't be decomposed into smaller groups.
15 years ago, this is 1995,
the last finite simple group,
the monster was discovered
by purely mathematical reasoning.
It's a finite group with a
considerable number of elements.
Then he writes down
the number of elements,
takes 54 digits to write
down the number of elements.
It's meaningless.
It's now being shown, he continues,
as a result of heroic
efforts that the list
of 26 finite simple
groups is indeed complete.
Now Connes writes, as
if the monster had been
just sitting out there quietly grinning,
waiting for us to discover it.
Now, there's a side tale
here bearing on stuff
about evidence and certainty and so forth.
The person who demonstrated
the existence of the monster
actually called it the Friendly Giant.
Any mathematician still
had doubts about the extent
to which this fact had been proven,
the fact, the existence of the monster
and the completeness of the classification
was actually not established till long
after Connes had written
his, those paragraph I quoted
by Ash Becker and Smith in Caltech.
That takes two volumes
to prove the result.
The reviewer, very
knowledgeable Ronald Solomon
in the bulletin of the
American Mathematical Society
asserts that no single person
will ever read the proof.
But a team has checked it, that is,
particularly the second volume
is divided into five parts
and five different people
check each bit of it.
Yet Connes like many others
had no doubts about that fact,
namely the existence of the monster
and the completeness of
system of finite groups
some 15 years earlier.
A nice example of the
way in which certainty
in mathematics has just changed.
Mathematicians soon made
sense of the monster.
That began with the prolifically
creative mathematician,
John Conway, with something he called
the monstrous moonshine conjecture.
It seems so preposterous
it was called moonshine,
because the monster
turned out to be identical
to an object derived,
from a completely different
branch of mathematics.
It had to be a coincidence,
there couldn't be any connection
between these two
completely disparate fields.
Moonshine, except it was
instead one of the cases
of the underlying unity within
the diversity of mathematics.
But here I want only to emphasize
Connes' heartfelt feeling
of experience that this at
first sight absurd object
was just there waiting for us.
And it's quite a common reaction.
Richard Borcherds, mentioned before
got his Fields Medal for proving
the moonshine conjecture.
In conversation he said, and
he's allowed me to quote this,
when you think about the monster,
you have to wonder who made it.
It's almost like that
intelligent design stuff.
The monster had such a complex
and yet organized structure
that it is if it had been
engineered by someone.
Now, he was honestly expressing
his persistent astonishment
about the sheer existence of the monster
that he had proved existed.
He was not advancing,
sorry, whose properties, whose
equivalents to something else
he had proved to exist.
He was not advancing an opinion,
he was expressing heartfelt
incredulity of a fact
that in any ordinary sense
he understood at least as well
as anyone else in the world.
He was not so much surprised at the fact
as by the existence of a such a fact.
He doesn't of course imagine
the monster had a designer.
He said only the object is
so complex and so delicate
in all its parts that it
as if it had been designed.
And Connes was giving vent
to the same sentiment.
But when they feel that he was also using
a certain sort of mathematicians rhetoric
to scare us into submission.
It didn't work on his fellow
debater, Jean-Pierre Changeux
who said the monster was just a bore.
So we're presented with
this meaningless sequence
of 54 digits, so we can see
that it actually factors
into some very interesting
primes, up to 71
which are called the
super singular primes.
But all the same, one is reminded
of Wittgenstein's remark about glitter.
We're supposed to be impressed when Connes
writes down the number
but somehow it's overdone.
Instead we're offering
what Wittgenstein called mysteriousness.
In the same context, he
asks, is it already alchemy
that mathematical propositions
are regarded as statements
about mathematical objects,
and mathematics as the
exploration of these objects?
That is Wittgenstein is saying look,
this a whole thing is a confidence trick.
It's that alchemy that
Connes takes for granted
and which he presents
as awesomely mysterious.
Mystery, glitter and
alchemy, Wittgenstein's words
are not all the same but
all three of these words
can be used to refract
different aspects of examples
like the monster.
Wittgenstein himself said,
all I can do is to show
an easy escape from this obscurity
and this glitter of concepts.
I don't believe there
is an easy escape from
this obscurity and glitter of concepts,
of the sort illustrated by Connes.
Maybe there is no escape.
It just is astonishing that
a few elementary axioms
or groups should generate
this extraordinary object
which turns out to be related
to a lot of other things,
and some people claim is even significant
for quantum field theory.
Connes is not an indiscriminate Platonist.
He does not think that
all mathematical objects
are like the monster, grinning
and waiting to be found.
His idea has more content
than Quine's semantic doctrine
that if we quantify over any class
then entities of that kind exist.
He's a highly discriminating ontologist.
He agrees that most of the
tools devised by mathematicians
are inventions not discoveries.
His labels for such tools is projective.
But they are used to
investigate what he calls,
strange words, really French, archaic
or primordial mathematical reality.
This is his way of expressing
a realism about mathematics
that is both modest and specific.
We construct mathematical
tools in abundance, he writes,
but what's remarkable is that using them,
we can identify uniquely
various objects that
are not in his opinion, constructed.
They constitute archaic, primitive,
original mathematical reality.
And at least the integers in his judgment
are a familiar part of that reality.
I don't share Connes'
convictions but I find them
more instructive than
blanket scholastic Platonism
which says without discrimination
that abstract objects exist,
or anything over which
we quantify exists.
The Nietzschean use of
grammar to undermine Platonism
is a powerful tool against the blanket,
but not against Connes.
But there's the neurobiological retort.
Jean-Pierre Changeux holds
that mathematical truth
is constrained by the neuronal
structure of the brain.
In answer to Connes' example, he retorts
that here we have merely,
I would say glittering,
an exotic example of the finite
list of regular polyhedra
which so impressed Plato.
And he writes that does
not prove despite Descartes
that we are concerned with properties
that are immutable and eternal.
Here he speaks as the neurobiologist
who doesn't really experience
mathematical proofs.
We can easily imagine a
lost dialogue in which
Socrates used the platonic
solids to make the same point
almost word-for-word
that Connes was making.
He was merely choosing an
example that was in 1989,
still recent and indeed
unfinished business.
My own opinion is much more obscure
than those of either of
the two controversialists.
I think that what Connes says is right,
but what he means is wrong.
He means a fabulous domain of numbers,
archaic and primordial whose structures
have nothing to do with the brain.
I think that what Changeux says is wrong
but what he means is right.
He means that the
structures Connes so admires
are byproducts of our genetic envelope.
Both men engage in a debate
that could be called archaic
in a technical sense of the word,
if Greeks before Thalys
had discovered proofs.
In fact, this debate is
merely ancient and athenian,
it began at the time of Plato.
It has stage props of today,
the newly discovered monster
and recent findings in cognitive
science pitted against it.
It's nevertheless the perennial debate.
It is one of the two underlying reasons
why we have philosophy
and mathematics at all.
The other is the sense
that somehow by proof
we discovered that which
is necessarily true.
Thank you very much.
(audience applause)
(mellow music)